[Music]
Check
it out, why don't you come here?
Oh,
and
then a
line will come from him, and I'll get it first,
so please stop misunderstanding
me.
Let's finish our homework quickly and go home
[music]
omecore i 7,
where is the
line
?
Wait a
minute a Oops, you're so persistent Hey,
buyout
[Music
] Even if it's Zaura, don't worry
about it, it's really languid
Video student
Video scene
[Laughter
] Speaking of which, Toro
Where is
it? It's
the bookshelf in the back.  I'll protect you,
sa hey,
nervousness at the venue He's dangerous, he's beyond the
point, no, no, no, no, no, this is a stage
where you can't stretch your arms.
Art Dama Doctor Association Kao Unazuki
Isn't the boyfriend on the floor handsome?
The woman,
along with Elizabeth, finally defeats the demon king
Well
, on the way home,
he is attacked by the soldiers of
the kingdom who were waiting for him.
Let's eat at the stake,
Mach
yeah, to
comment on this
Cheek-free is a senior, isn't it?
I'm not going
to pay for the creative act of my senior, the beautiful female knight inside and Ogura
.
It's easy to understand here, but
haha, Shira, who can only live in the midst of a battle,
has such a dark tone
.
That
's
why it's so cute
What's going on?  A strange woman who can only live
I threw it away
, I thought it was enough ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooohhhhhhhhhhh 6 look at the attic
it's going to be a horror it
's like love  There's
no way you can do something like a watermark that's only allowed in a campaign that doesn't exist right now,
ca
n't you?
When people are doing flowers, make
sure to look
them in the eye.
Chattaha Bee Bye Sentai Uh-huh Poupe
Thread,
that version is that
guy's silly voice. It
was burned into my mind and I couldn't sleep
.
UUUUUUU UUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUU up)
What a day
!
Come on,
senpai, you're cold
[music]
Uho
Oh
, oh, oh,
I'll be your model for senpai Ichi-
hope I don't feel like writing lies to
passers-by.  I'm going with a more erotic feeling
You seem to like seniors
Jaguar It's easy to show your skin
Oh
[music]
If you're at it, say this
tan
I've been eating kendori for a while now, but
maybe I haven't eaten it at all.
I've never done anything like that, so I
'll give you
5 senpai if you can write it properly.
I've been writing since I'm writing this
video I think it's okay to die Oh
by this guy,
put on a taiyu
[applause]
I see, is
this the best of seniors?
It's okay, it's fine
,
so I'll
use it first.
Isn't it around
here?  I wonder if
it's a fun scene to observe Senpai
What is that?
[Applause]
I'm weak when I scold
my seniors.
I didn't
have one, but I also had
this kind of junior Senior, please write it properly
next time I'll give you a great reward, so I won't be able to enter
Candidate Lobby or
Senior Senior Center
Sour sour
Why is this guy on the same roundabout?
I know it
's strange to say something like this right after we met,
but
please
do it with me.  Do you think it's possible for a senior to
become rooted
in Kokura from a girl?
[Music] It
's not even a stain
kemet yahoo karu 1st
battle There's
nothing wrong with being a pedestal
Pawn
I think I'm doing something pretty tough, but
Shiga 2nd
is the same as the guys up until now
8  Kyosho's
new manga b Please,
I've been in this situation a lot since long ago, so I know how to deal
with it, so I'm afraid I'm going to have a good
time.
I don't even remember his face
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, why don't you talk about
him?
To be honest, it's
frustrating and it's been a
long time since
I've been in the
middle of a
long time.
Peach
oh oh oh oh
oh
[music]
Hehe
Nagata Lotte Please choose
him Nice to meet you
Senpai
[music]
wh
aname
[music]
ban
dna
nina
na na
me
ana
canana tanna  na na na
[music]
hane
ran
[music]
ha
nai
ana
me
me let's repeat
[Music]
Well then, it's a reflection pointer.